hello everybody don't Walker here many
of you have been telling me the news
about Michael Bay's decision to make
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles actually
teenage alien Ninja Turtles yeah there's
been a lot of uproar about this people
have been getting very upset very angry
they feel he's not being faithful to the
original source material and that's it's
going against everything that the Ninja
Turtles are I mean right down to the
very name what they are and a lot of
people have been wondering what my
opinion on it is all I have to say is
are you people fucking nuts this is
great the spectacular oh okay all right
for all you doubters out there that
think you know that this this is a
travesty this is horrible this is you
know a bad bad thing let me tell you
something
shame on you okay shame on you that only
now are you realizing that late Michael
Bay director is a bad idea
I mean it's dead on arrival okay as soon
as you hear Michael Bay's teenage
whatever Ninja Turtles you know it's
gonna be dead
you know it's gone so oh my god what why
were you even invested why were you even
thinking that you were gonna go see this
expecting something good I mean this is
like shit directing crap and expecting
something but no you're just gonna get
shit you just pray that the smell is
gonna be so different and so odd because
you never seen shit direct crap that
it's gonna be a new experience and you
know what I am hyped for this new
experience I mean once you totally put
away that the Ninja Turtles are gone and
dead you know Michael Bay got the cell
phone buried them ah there's no telling
where this will go
I mean this can just lead anywhere for
example um why start at mutant I mean as
of now that had to be teenage alien
engine turns but
it's a Michael Bay film let's go all the
way let's get all these trademarks in
there let's see a teenage well it goes
without saying they'd be teenagers
because everybody has movies are so
let's get rid of that something else
something else that what keeps showing
up in his movies over and over races
yes I mean not that necessary the
characters are racist although they are
splinter he's agent right so you can
give him the great big black glasses of
Google because he's a rat all right but
forgive me even bigger teeth a vehicle
Oh Dean encounter calls
oh you kicked out the my launching mat
oh he'll be so offensive kakarakaya okay
well we can go to like the ghetto crowd
right wait we can make like Raphael a
brother okay and we can get like a
golden teeth and you know and everyone's
gonna watch it looking like that's so
offensive skip yeah that's Michael Bay
bitch that's Michael Bay only okay okay
um so so we got research now we got
racist we got alien what else what else
um well I think we all know what's
coming up next the turtles have to have
tips they have to have large tits on top
of it I know they're not female but
you'll change that Michelangelo chick
dun you know I mean just given these
huge huge breath give her these huge
huge brands and he'll be like - like a
big big Bratz I need to hold this on a
car and spray water on me because
Michael Bay has such respect for my mind
it'll be unbelievable you can't make
Michelangelo and shake it don't feel
like it's Michael packy that's what he
does okay okay so we got um racist alien
big boo bead you know don't even make
him Turtles anymore
Oh what does Michael Bay like just make
them explosions literally just have them
beat for explosions with masks on that's
it so literally you will have Michael
Bay's racist alien big boobies
explosions can you people honestly tell
me that you are not curious to see
Michael Bay's racist alien big boobies
explosions I are about the ticket the
idea isn't even done and I bought the
ticket
this is why he keeps making movies
people are just like I gotta know what
the fuck he's gonna do cuz he is goddamn
nuts and I'm sorry but I'm just enjoying
the ride I mean I know everyone expects
me to be sure angry and stuff like that
but just the minute you hear Michael Bay
is on board
you just forget any sense of good how
can you make the title Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles dumber than it already
sounds and Michael Bay's name to it yes
people
I am hyped I cannot wait to see Michael
Bay's racist alien big boobies
explosions I and you know what if you
don't want to see it that's your loss
dude that's totally your loss I am Doug
Walker
I am fucking height